dans cette salle de sport à montigny le
bretonneux les machines de musculation
sont à l'arrêt une situation qui agace
le directeur c'est bien de dire je
comprends la colère mais ça fait en deux
ans trois ans ça fait un peu beaucoup
d'eux on comprend oui oui je comprends
mais bon surtout je fais rien je
comprends donc c'est beaucoup de mots
c'est beaucoup de sémantique beaucoup de
de sophismes j'ai envie de dire
aujourd'hui on aimerait avoir des actes
quoi qu'ils comprennent qu'ils nous
montrent vraiment qu'ils pensent à notre
situation c'est pour cela qu'un
rassemblement devant l'assemblée
nationale a été organisée ce mardi 12
janvier après midi par le collectif
touche pas à ma salle pour protester
contre la fermeture des salles de sport
pour ce directeur il s'agit en plus d'un
véritable paradoxe
le sport ça a été un mal lutter contre
les problèmes de santé ça renforce le
système immunitaire sa lutte contre le
diabète de type 2 l'obésité
cette salle d' escalade à montigny le
bretonneux est fermée elle aussi au
public depuis huit mois
son dirigeant attend davantage d aide en
attendant vu qu'ils ont pris la décision
de fermer c'est de nous aider simplement
ce que là on en parlait des aides et des
milliards qui sont débloqués pour
l'instant on n'en voit pas grand chose
tout ce qu'on voit c'est un fonds de
solidarité qui va monter à 20% du
chiffre d'affaires ce qui couvre même
pas les loyers une période d'autant plus
difficile pour ces établissements qui
sont prêts à rouvrir avec des mesures
strictes on avait imposé le port du
masque pour la lah pour la pratique de
la discipline
on avait du gel hydroalcoolique par tous
les gens ici dans des salles d'aude
escalade se désinfecter mans continue et
malgré ça derrière on our ferme 1 1
on ne vise pas qu'on lit mal c'est qu'on
a l'impression qu'on nous prend pour des
imbéciles
ces deux salles de sport accueille quand
même des personnes munies d'une
ordonnance et les professionnels du
sport grâce au décret qui le permettent
mais cela ne suffira pas pour couvrir
tous leurs frais